Ever wondered about the deepest secret desire
of SCP-106, the Old Man who drags unsuspecting
victims into his hellish pocket dimension?
Foundation researchers snapped a picture of
SCP-106 as he emerged from a wall, using SCP-978,
the Desire Camera.
This was the result:
"SCP-106 roaming a wheat field.
Appears to be approaching an old farmhouse,
while a woman, appearing to be in her mid-sixties,
welcomes 106."
SCP-106's origins are uncertain, but it has
always seemed clear that he desired fear and
violence over all else.
This photograph tells a different story, one
of a man who wants comfort, love, and a home
of his own.
It's a fascinating look into the innermost
desires of someone that seems like a simple
monster.
Sadly, he will never have the home he yearns
for, condemned to hunt forever and destroy
everything he touches.